hello said bored here with AGS news
update every year nintendo president
reggie fils-aime a takes to the e3 stage
to make dreams come true except last
year and now apparently this year too
what about my dreams ready what about my
dreams for the second year in a row
Mario and Zelda company Nintendo will
forgo a traditional III press conference
in favor of a digital presentation
nintendo announced today that it will
hold a nintendo digital event what it
calls a new kind of video program at
nine a.m. PT on Tuesday June tenth
that's Nintendo's typical Tuesday slot
one day after Microsoft and Sony hold
their press briefings in Los Angeles on
Monday jun 9th the nintendo digital
event will bring news about games coming
to nintendo platforms in 2014 and beyond
nintendo said no further specifics have
been announced we demonstrated last year
that we are never afraid to reinvent a
proven tactic or to break completely new
ground if we believe it will provide the
best experience for our fans followers
and partners nintendo of america
president Reggie Fiza may said in a
statement but in a bizarre video with
mega 64 Nintendo confirmed it will be
holding a super smash brothers
Invitational at the nokia theatre
they'll also be nintendo treehouse live
at e3 a special booth on the e3 show
floor will provide attendees in-depth
gaming demos being live streamed all day
during e3 they'll also be super smash
brothers smash fest at Best Buy allowing
shoppers to play super smash brothers
wii u ahead of release in stores so do
you prefer Nintendo's digital
presentation are were you holding out
the original live event what's your
favorite Reggie fiza may mines zombie
Reggie ah I like French food before this
leave us a comment and don't forget that
you can check out sony and microsoft's
conferences from this year's e3 right
here at gamespot com and stick around
for more gaming updates